and now for a first trip abroad is that
right yeah that's right tonight in Paris
the Oscar winner for a compelling
performance and room at the top is
starring in the French version of the
little foxes so from the stage of the
Sarah Bernhardt theater here is miss
Simone Signoret
editing is the next craft to receive an
award as you know the writer gets a
nightly that's the beginning but who is
on the other hand after the story has
been put on film on hundreds of of
pieces of film that must move so
smoothly and excitingly that you are
seldom aware of a change the film editor
long after the actors writers the
cameraman and all the technicians have
completed the shooting the film editors
job continues through the dubbing the
scoring and the first review then the
director and producer decide whether or
not the film editors work is finished if
not continues until their final print is
ready for release and every inch of that
film has gone through his skillful hands
the award will be presented by a
versatile actor who won his proof is
Oscar for his performance in a streetcar
named desire here is a method actor who
do more than scratch mr. Carl Hall
thank you no I'm not acting now the
nominees for film editing are and coats
for Lawrence of Arabia Samuel EB plea
for the longest day terrorists Webster
for The Manchurian Candidate
william Ziegler for Meredith Willson's
of The Music Man
John McSweeney Jr for mutiny on the
bounty
Miller thank you and coats for Lawrence
of Arabia
accepting on behalf of an goats mr.
Robert Stack
the task of putting together a motion
picture the size of Lawrence of Arabia
must be a monumental one well and Costra
put together the tune of 10 nominations
to award so far in the night is young I
know how much she wishes you could be
here to thank you in person